[Musique]
ils ont quitté leurs uniformes et sont
venus de toute la france pour défendre
leurs maîtresses que vous travaillez
dans des mauvaises conditions
aujourd'hui nous marseille et nous
dirons non monsieur le ministre rwandais
du service public
ils sont flic de base brigadier ou
gardiens de la paix et ils ont répondu
au mot d'ordre du syndicat qui les
représente majoritairement il faut que
le gouvernement nous dit de frêche main
s'il veut anéantir
et s'il veut être le fossoyeur de la
police nationale qui le disent la liste
des revendications est longue
commissariat souvent vétustes
sous-effectif fermetures de postes en
province et horaires de travail remises
en cause les raisons d'un profond
malaise dans la profession depuis le
début de l'année 30 policiers se sont
suicidés
un véritable drame toujours sans réponse
[Musique]